[Música]
gracias por acompañarme una semana más
de medio ambiente de france 24 si
queremos hacer las paces con la
naturaleza tenemos que empezar ya mismo
a implementar cambios radicales en
nuestro modo de vida así lo recuerda una
vez más el último informe del programa
de la onu para el medio ambiente que
ofrece un plan para abordar la triple
emergencia planetaria el cambio
climático la pérdida de biodiversidad y
la contaminación el documento se basa en
lo que ya nos han estado diciendo en
estos últimos años varios estudios
científicos internacionales según
antonio guterres el secretario general
de las naciones unidas este reporte es
el plan de paz para un programa de
reconstrucción tras la guerra contra el
planeta en la que estamos sumidos en sus
palabras es un documento que sienta las
bases de la esperanza
quiero ser claro sin la ayuda de la
naturaleza no prosperaremos ni
sobreviviremos durante demasiado tiempo
hemos estado librando una guerra suicida
y sin sentido contra la naturaleza
y el resultado son tres crisis
medioambientales interrelacionadas
alteración del clima pérdida de
biodiversidad y contaminación que
amenazan nuestra viabilidad como
especies son causados por una producción
y un consumo insostenibles el bienestar
humano radica en proteger la salud del
planeta es hora de reevaluar y
restablecer nuestra relación con la
naturaleza este informe puede ayudarnos
a hacerlo en distree ports que en el pas
del sol
el texto presenta un plan científico que
explica cómo hacerle frente de manera
conjunta a estas tres crisis ambientales
detalla que puede y que tiene que hacer
cada sector desde los políticos hasta
los medios de comunicación pasando por
científicos ciudadanía y entidades
financieras en tres aspectos el primero
que las soluciones deben aplicarse
teniendo en cuenta el enfoque de una
sola salud es decir integrar acciones
que protejan al tiempo la salud de las
personas los animales y el medio
ambiente el segundo la transformación de
los sistemas económicos y financieros
para que sean motores de cambio hacia la
sostenibilidad y tercero transformar los
sistemas alimentarios hídricos y
energéticos para que puedan satisfacer
las necesidades de una creciente
población pero respetando el medio
ambiente
en definitiva piden que cambiemos
nuestro modo de vida
the only answer y sustainable
development a es el desarrollo
sostenible que eleva el bienestar tanto
de las personas como del planeta el
informe apunta a muchas formas en que
podemos lograr esto
por ejemplo los gobiernos pueden incluir
el capital natural en las medidas de
desempeño económico y promover una
economía circular pueden acordar no
apoyar el tipo de agricultura que
destruye o contamina la naturaleza
pueden poner precio al carbono pueden
cambiar los subsidios de los
combustibles fósiles hacia soluciones
bajas en carbono y amigables con la
naturaleza la conclusión es que
necesitamos transformar la forma en que
vemos y valoramos la naturaleza debemos
reflejar el verdadero valor de la
naturaleza en todas nuestras políticas
planes y sistemas económicos economics y
distraen leiter andrade strain world
notw y consider estamos destruyendo la
naturaleza y la riqueza pero lo
consideramos crecimiento del pib muchas
otras actividades que destruyen la
naturaleza y que menoscaban nuestro
futuro están todavía consideradas parte
del crecimiento de la economía global
hay un cambio fundamental en la forma en
que medimos la economía y en la forma en
que nos comportamos como ciudadanos y la
manera en que nos
como países y sin ese cambio fundamental
los objetivos que nos hemos fijado en
relación con biodiversidad colusión y
cambio climático no serán alcanzables y
estamos cercanos al punto de no retorno
si nuevo and we are close to point now
gritan otras recomendaciones para los
gobiernos están relacionadas con el
diseño de ciudades sostenibles desde el
punto de vista social y ambiental con
infraestructura que sea eficiente
energéticamente por ejemplo se estima
que el 56 por ciento de la población
mundial vive en ciudades un porcentaje
que sube al 81% en américa latina así
que el papel de estas para un futuro
sostenible es crucial pero las
recomendaciones como decíamos antes no
son sólo para los gobiernos a las
organizaciones financieras les piden que
apoyen proyectos de conservación y
restauración de biodiversidad y se
alejen de financiar industrias que
contribuyen al calentamiento global y
también al cambio climático además que
adopten la riqueza inclusiva que es la
suma del capital producido el capital
natural el humano y el social como
de las decisiones en materia de
inversión y dejen de usar el pib como
índice de desarrollo al sector privado
le piden más prácticas de economía
circular es decir reducir desechos
reutilizar materias y reciclar más y
para la ciudadanía a exponer la
importancia de participar en la elección
de líderes políticos y en exigir
responsabilidades a estos funcionarios
también ser más conscientes de nuestras
decisiones diarias en cuanto al consumo
de energía de recursos o de alimentos y
que apoyemos el comercio justo y la
producción sostenible local por ejemplo
y a los medios de comunicación nos dan
la responsabilidad de entre otras cosas
desmentir información falsa y documentar
e informar sobre la relación directa que
hay entre la destrucción de la
naturaleza y el empeoramiento de
nuestras condiciones de vida el informe
hace hincapié en que la pandemia de kobe
19 es una consecuencia directa de la
destrucción de hábitats y que hay que
aprovechar los paquetes de estímulo
económico para reconstruir alejándose de
las prácticas insostenibles y dirigiendo
el dinero hacia infraestructuras y
program
y que reduzcan los riesgos y las
repercusiones de las pandemias en el
futuro con este documento la onu
pretende que se establezca una base de
la que salgan soluciones concretas
durante las reuniones clave que se darán
en 2021 sobre el medio ambiente y que
llegan con un año de retraso por el
brote de coronavirus la cumbre sobre
biodiversidad en la ciudad china de
kunming en mayo y la cumbre sobre cambio
climático en glasgow escocia que se
celebrará los primeros 12 días de
noviembre es todo por esta semana hay
más medio ambiente en france24 punto com
[Música]